the island pagoda south of Yangon is
just one of the many tourist attractions
in Myanmar there are also many
monasteries in the area but not everyone
has time to appreciate such priceless
cultural treasures Jim Taylor has lived
in the country since 2004 and is married
to a Burmese woman whom he met in the
United States together they've dedicated
their lives to fighting poverty in
Myanmar Taylor and his team developed
this water pump the simple irrigation
system has greatly increased for meals
in this veg farmer Shen keen can now
plant cucumbers and harvest his crops
three times a year something previously
unthinkable oh these look pretty good oh
nice yeah yeah so this is a good size
okay very good
shame keen is proud he bought his first
water pump in 2005 for just a few
dollars where it soon spread about the
new technology we have a picture in our
office of when we first brought we
actually didn't make the pumps the very
first month we were here we imported
about 15 from India and we took them to
a village north of Yangon and we set
them down brought him in the village and
and farmers gathered around them and
they started tinkering with them they
taking apart and I knew we had something
because they were really interested in
it this is how Burmese people have
gotten their water for centuries women
did most of the back-breaking labor but
now such toil is the exception in this
village this man and his family now have
access to water just outside their door
the pumps construction is simple and
inexpensive but it's also built to last
Jim Taylor is a social entrepreneur his
products are meant to better the lives
of farmers he doesn't give them away for
free but his company proximity designs
does help farmers for whom a few dollars
are a virtual fortune arrange affordable
financing well the social part is that
we're using we're we're products that
help people improve their incomes and as
social good because people are able to
then send their children to school eat
better and be more prosperous in their
village the idea is to help people
escape poverty without making them
dependent on handouts this farmer tells
us that his family now has enough to eat
with its population of 4 million Yangon
is a world away from the problems of
farmers in the countryside
since Yangon has opened up more and more
Burmese exiles are returning Taylor
employs many Burmese designers and
product developers in his socially
conscious business
so that both way that forced dissolution
all that you some of them had lucrative
jobs abroad and took pay cuts to work
here these people would rather design
water filters than golf bags or luxury
cars the big challenge is to create
affordable products getting to find
solutions that actually save people a
lot of time and increase their income is
I think it's I think it's very rewarding
work proximity employs more than 300
people
several dozen work in Yangon others sell
and explain the products to farmers in
changing to some off-the-shelf or rings
imported from Thailand and we're trying
to figure out which ones are the best
fit for our design and
the hardness that we want for the
particular Oh ring this is where
products are tested how much water can
be pumped onto fields by foot without
over exertion which collection system
can withstand the tropical climate
in a typical season a farmer will travel
about a hundred thousand times so we try
to simulate that before it goes into the
field so we're confident as a pump will
break the rainy season for a few weeks
there will be no shortage of water
it's lunchtime in a typical Burmese
restaurant a meal for five people costs
around ten dollars Taylor's wife is
currently in the US developing contacts
Harvard University for example is
carrying out studies to help proximity
while Stanford is sending designers
there wasn't a sense of optimism there
was more of a sense of fatalism now
people are optimistic about the future
young people see an opportunity to get
education there is jobs there's you know
working with having more connections
internationally one quarter of old
Burmese lives below the poverty line
something Taylor aims to change since
the political opening in 2011 Myanmar
has developed by leaps and bounds and
now entrepreneurs are using their new
freedoms to help others get on boards
the new prosperity
you